everything consists of combinations of
the four basic elements earth air fire
and water
said the Greek philosopher empedocles
today we know that earth air fire and
water do not constitute the smallest and
most basic components these four
elements however still symbolized the
basic the simple and the pure one might
be tempted to say that this also applies
to the Black Diamond the new Royal
Library on the waterfront in the city
center of Copenhagen
life is born of water
plankton became amphibians which became
mammals that crawled out of the sea and
up onto dry land from the very beginning
water has also played a key role in the
building the waterfront location in the
centre of the city close to library
users and close to a number of
particularly important historic
buildings turned the creation of the
construction pit into a special
challenge
haha man lil it gon dance we've created
a system of lowering the ground water
level in the deepest layer of limestone
when pumping out the groundwater it's
very important to pump just the right
amount if we pump too much we'll be in
trouble with the neighboring buildings
the brewery the armory and finally the
provisions Depot all 15th century
buildings founded on wooden piles and if
these piles dry out
in the beginning most of the work on the
building site took place below water
level several meters of the harbor were
reclaimed this was truly work in depth
I'm here for fear that listen we're down
to about four meters or something about
that we're laying tie bars to make sure
that the sheet piling at the bottom does
not slide because we're frightened that
the ground might be too soft just like
any other job
some days are hard others are easy
before construction started several
years of planning went into the library
the Ministry of Culture announced an
architectural competition in March it
was a double competition one asking for
a project describing the extension of
the royal library the other calling for
an assessment of the proposed extension
in the general context of an overall
plan for the waterfront between the two
bridges that was the project unanimous
committee headed by the then Minister of
Culture Udo Hilton selected the proposal
by architects Schmidt hammer and lesson
from 179 candidates the committee found
the project recommended for construction
very convincing and that's just as well
coming from me as I'm the one with the
money to realize the proposal I think it
looks like a black diamond there's a
rumor going around saying that we almost
gave up in the office a few days before
the competition project was due that we
didn't know where we were going and that
one of us at that point slapped the
black model so hard that it broke thus
producing the slanting and tilting shape
of the building that of course is not
the true story the true story is that we
have tried to express the flexibility
and dynamics of dignity of this national
institution and of the cityscape with
all the surrounding government
institutions but the black diamond and
water you think of the proximity of the
harbor the reflections of the water in
the facade inside the building in the
atrium and in all the offices on a more
spiritual level you might think of how
alluring water has always been into man
water symbolizes the liquid the
continuous new and old side-by-side
continuity and renewal
extension not relocation
earth the second of the four elements is
often used as a symbol for what is hard
cold and that which can carry a heavy
load the Granite's of the facade was
quarried in Zimbabwe in Africa the huge
blocks were cut and polished in Italy
the glass of the atrium facing the
waterfront and the specially designed
wires and fittings that provide the
great sense of lightness and
transparency were produced in Germany
the steel the beam carrying the weight
of the entire structure was constructed
in Poland this and many other of the
large elements of the building had to be
transported by night so as not to
disrupt the traffic
traffic was a factor that had to be
considered at all times so the link
between the old and the new building is
an 18 metre wide bridge crossing
questions polygons the inner ring road
of Copenhagen
the black diamond and earth well it's
the colors the nuance is expressed in
the building in the exterior as well as
the interior particularly perhaps in the
dark granite it's the depth of the
Queen's Hall
err the light the open the inconstant
the black cube floats over the surface
of the earth and the atrium opens
outwards to the water and upwards to the
sky light flexible and simple as air
all life in the building radiates from
the atrium the lending bridge the link
to the old building providing access to
centers and reading rooms to the Queen's
Hall to the exhibitions to the shop and
restaurant
the simplicity and pure nostalgia
did not come without cost in time or
technology the entity the right solution
is always the simple solution layer upon
layer is never good in order to live up
to the architects concept we worked
really hard on shapes and details in
order to finally reach this minimalistic
expression none of the four outer walls
has the same slope conventional building
techniques were inadequate so the
library is constructed like a bridge a
suspension bridge with the four concrete
towers functioning as pylons that bear
the weight of the entire building the
black diamond and air well its first and
foremost the room the atrium of the
chasm the lightness expressed in the
height of the room at the transparency
and the skylight gives like directly to
the activities in the room and
indirectly to all the adjoining reading
rooms
as life crawled out of the oceans onto
dry land
it was the mastery of fire the
all-consuming element that transformed
the ape into man fire is one of the
books worst enemies every part every
square inch of the library therefore is
built with safety in mind although
barring constructions are wrapped in
rock wall which will withstand much more
than the 1,000 degrees centigrade a fire
can generate safety also means
sophisticated technology helping the
security guards to protect the many
irreplaceable books manuscripts
photographs and globes as construction
went on outside many of the library's
employees worked intensely and under
very difficult conditions inside to
ensure the improved and greater
diversity of service that the black
diamonds can provide the library had to
reduce public services during
construction and closed the main
building on Castle Island to the public
the operation clear project has
processed more than a hundred thousand
books ready for placing on the open
shelves and the new reading rooms and
centers there are 10 kilometres of open
shelves room for 300 thousand volumes
others have worked on a new electronic
library system
Rex 2000 which was taken into use in
March 1999 still more worked on
digitizing collections the image
database now has more than 50 thousand
searchable images music manuscripts and
much more is now available and
accessible electronically through the
internet the new building expresses the
concept defined by the library at the
outset of the project a combination of
culture center and national library an
open structure in an open space
you mean the black diamond and fire well
it's a practical consideration the black
diamond and fire add after safety and
security in terms of our architectural
perception fire symbolizes sole
character heart and this building is
drawn by hand and seen by our hearts the
fertility which is the result of
cultural diversity incorporated in a new
library concept is found in the
transparency throughout the building in
the numerous exhibitions in the cultural
section in the various centers and
reading rooms in the library part and in
the proximity to other cultural
institutions under the same roof in the
adjoining building called the fish
this Egon if we don't preserve the past
for future generations to study but then
quite simply we lose our consciousness
our cultural heritage and our
self-knowledge our roots and it could be
said that we're not Danish anymore the
library's task is to preserve that which
is specifically Danish and that which is
of foreign origin but has been part of
Denmark
over the centuries we collect and
preserve the works of Hans Christian
Andersen's and Keokuk or kind Blixen and
Klaus wife Pierre to name but a few
it's materials such as research archives
book collections and photo archives all
this must be preserved safely nothing
must perish either by use or by
deterioration the library opened in
September 1999 by Queen Mercator is not
only a new building but also a strong
renewal of its contents its services and
its public facilities fire air water and
earth spirit and matter expressed and
realized with the black diamond on the
Copenhagen waterfront
copy that TV is now complete thank you
you